let's talk a little bit about animal
communication and in general
communication is one party giving
information to another party somehow and
it doesn't even have to be one-to-one it
could be one person giving or one animal
for talk about animal communication
giving information to many other many
other animals and communication doesn't
even just have to happen between animals
there's a plant can actually communicate
to an animal through its appearance or
by releasing certain chemicals but we'll
focus in this video on animal
communication and it's interesting
because we even we humans are animals
and the more that we think about this
the more types of communication we'll
see around us it'll be interesting to
think about why we do that communication
and how we do it so let's think about
the types of animal communication so we
can think of visual and visual
communication just me drawing a diagram
like that is a form of visual
communications so we could have things
like pictures pictures diagrams writing
writings interesting because it's
conveying kind of thought ideas it is
conveying information and it's something
you look at so I would put writing here
writing you have even more basic types
of visual communication even if we stick
to human beings
the most obvious one I can think of is
facial expressions if you see someone
who is who seems as a smile like that
and you know they seem very approachable
it feels like hey they're communicating
even if they're not consciously doing
and then hey you can approach me I'm
friendly why don't you come talk to me
we're a week we can hang out while if
someone looks like this where they're
kind of glaring where someone looks like
this then you might say okay this person
doesn't look like they want to be
bothered right now maybe maybe I'm I'm
not interested in in messing with that
person and when you think about facial
expressions it's very it's very
fundamental for us human beings but why
do why are we why do we view this one on
the left is more friendly and this one
on the right is more aggressive what's
through millions of years of evolution
that these things just
came about and we recognized kind of an
aggressive posture or friendly posture
in our own species and in other species
as well we know what a dog is is showing
its teeth that okay maybe I don't want
to mess with it as much but if it's
wagging its tail okay maybe it's maybe
it's in a friendly mood and similarly
it's not just pictures and diagrams and
writing and facial expressions
it could be body postures this is true
of humans it's also true of other
animals there's a whole TED talk on
these power poses these poses that you
can take on that can kind of establish
your your dominance in in a in an
environment especially with other humans
but it's probably not just humans but
also with other animals you'll also see
if you watch you know these these nature
specials on TV animals striking certain
poses that exhibit their dominance in
some way or their position in some type
of a social hierarchy
you also have animals just by the nature
of their appearance that are
communicating with other animals for
example there's a lot of animals that by
their coloration they're signaling to
other animals that hey it's probably not
a good idea to eat me for example if
this is a frog right over here it's not
that well drawn of a frog but frogs are
famous especially some of the ones that
have these vibrant colors that these are
signals to other potential predators
that hey you don't want to eat me I will
I am poisonous I will likely make you
sick or even kill you if you eat me and
the Predators know that it could either
be innate through millions of years of
evolution though the ones that have
learned to avoid the colors live on and
pass their genes or it might be
sometimes some type of learned behavior
that they've tried to eat one of these
frogs once and it made them really sick
so they're gonna avoid it again as we
know visual isn't the only type of
communication in fact normally when we
talk about communications we often think
of a speech and language or a spoken
language so I'll write that down a
speech so let me write or let me write
auditory auditory communication and that
could be speech that could be that could
be
this could be a some type of a bark a
dog barking saying hey stay away from
here don't mess with me it could be a
roar a lion's roar might be a way of
saying hey I'm dominant here don't come
here or if you're a potential mate if
you're a lion is saying hey look how
nice my roar is wouldn't you want to
come and start a family with me and it
doesn't even have to be something that
kind of comes them it comes from your
throat it could be it could be beating
of the chest by a gorilla once again to
exert its dominance in some way it could
be some sound that an animal does as a
warning to other animals to run away
because it sees a predator so we can
keep thinking of more and more examples
of each of these forms of communication
now other forms of communication that
might be a little bit less obvious you
have chemical chemical communication so
what's an example of chemical
communication well we know that a lot of
animals including dogs like to mark
their territory with by with urine and
when other animals come by especially
other dogs they'll smell that urine that
might have been applied to a tree
someplace this is okay this is some
other dog's territory I'm gonna go
someplace else
there's things like pheromones let me
write this down
pheromones pheromones are chemical
signals even humans emit pheromones that
are not necessarily consciously but
subconsciously sensed by other humans
and they can drive attraction between
those humans once again its chemical
signals one animal is giving information
to another now another form of
communication once again not as obvious
is tactile tactile communication and
this could be a form of kind of a
nurturing touch by the mother to
communicate to the child that it is safe
it could be a warning you could imagine
you know you're in a dinner party and
your significant other kind of steps on
your toe when you find yourself saying
things that you shouldn't say that's all
tactile communication hey don't
you know I'm giving you the information
that you're starting to talk about
something that you're not supposed to
talk about so now that we've talked
about some of these general forms of
communication and I encourage you just
look around either your own life or just
the animal world and think about all the
forms of communication around you let's
think about why animals actually
communicate including humans and we
often think ourselves to somehow beyond
the natural world but when you really
think about it most of our forms of
communication fall into the categories
we're about to talk about one category
is coordinate group behavior coordinate
group behavior so for example if we are
about to go fight in a war there might
be communication about well how do we
approach the enemy in what order do we
do it it could be a team where we make a
plan either visual or auditory plan
somehow I don't know how you could
actually do a chemical plan but that
would be interesting there's other
things you could be you could be caring
for the young as your main purpose for
communication care for young once again
it could be something like tactile or
even visual communication or auditory
communication that makes the young field
nurtured or you might be training them
in some way in fact even this video even
the whole notion of Khan Academy it's a
form of communication that you know you
could argue is about coordinating group
behavior in some way helping to educate
more people so that they can participate
in a better way or you could view it as
caring for the young or some combination
but there's other reasons why you
communicate you could be defending
territory you could be just a new color
you could be defending defending
territory obviously something like a no
trespassing sign does it very explicitly
in fact even a fence the existence of a
fence is a form of communication and
obviously in the animal world we can
think of it all the time with a bark or
with you know
leaving your chemical signature on a
tree to say hey this is you don't don't
come here this is my territory and a
very big role or use of communication
you'll see throughout the animal world
even in humans if you really think about
it is in finding a mate is in finding a
mate you know when someone goes buys
that fancy sports car it's probably more
than they need just to get from point A
to point B but it might signal something
to potential mates that hey I have a lot
of earning power or I'm flashy or
whatever else it might be and related to
that is you might want to signal some
type of dominance and that dominance
might be for potential mate or it might
be to defend your territory tell other
people to step aside or that hey you
should be the one that's coordinating
the group's behavior instead of instead
of someone else